faster faster James drives goes right at  Turner backs and hold onto overdue James  drives gets inside and finishes once  again comes out with more desperation in  the next one James steps back two-point  shot is good James right now named steps  back inside the arc jumpers good games  that's a two-pointer got it James the  other free-throw line gets inside the  double came late third straight time  spins drives banks at home love back to  James James drive scoop layup miss the  following banks at all Bogdanovich's the  good work wall series lon  Hill to James James the flush  James three-pointer Oladipo seeing the  trap once again locked out of it's lost  the ball James finds it to Hill James  looking for an opening east double the  Korver five to shoot back to James for  the layin all in a passive barber